So, I search for how to record audio in swift.
And in here, I found this Stack Overflow.
By the way, the link to this Stack Overflow with some helpful code
is available in the instructor notes.
Now, one thing software engineers will do on a regular basis is that they will
read code that other people have written, and they will try and
figure out how that code works.
And here is our opportunity to practice that.
This is the code I got from Stack Overflow with a few changes that I made.
Now, we know that this code can help us record audio.
See if you can figure out how the different lines of the code can help us
accomplish that goal.
In other words, try and
translate this code into simple English, and enter your thoughts in this box.
By the way, this code is also available in the instructor notes for
you to experiment with.